JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS.
SHE FLIES FIRST CLASS ON A PAPER
AIRPLANE.
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
SHERIFF SCOTT ISRAEL WAS GRILLED
BY JAKE TAPPER SUNDAY.
THE OFFICIAL DID EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO AVOID BLAME FOR THE
BLUNDERS LEADING TO THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING.
AT TIMES, HE SEEMED LIKE HE WAS
READING FROM A FORTUNE COOKIE.
>> DO YOU THINK IF THE BROWARD
SHERIFF'S OFFICE HAD DONE THINGS
DIFFERENTLY, THIS SHOOTING MIGHT
NOT HAVE HAPPENED?
>> LISTEN, CANDY AND NUTS,
O.J. SIMPSON WOULD BE IN THE
RECORD BOOKS.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
17 PEOPLE KILLED IN AS A WHOLE
LIST OF THINGS YOUR APARTMENT
COULD HAVE DONE DIFFERENTLY.
>> Greg: IF IFs AND BUTS
WERE CANDY AND NUTS.
HE ALSO SAID THIS WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE.
>> ARE YOU ARE NOT TAKING ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE MULTIPLE
RED FLAGS BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION OF THE BROWARD
SHERIFF'S OFFICE ABOUT THE
SHOOTER.
>> I CAN ONLY TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT I KNEW
ABOUT.
I EXERCISED MY DUE DILIGENCE.
I'VE GIVEN AMAZING LEADERSHIP TO
THIS AGENCY.
>> Greg: AMAZING.
HE IS LESS A SHERIFF AND MORE A
POLITICIAN.
LIKE A POLITICIAN, HE IS TRYING
TO HIS BUTT.
HOPEFULLY THE MEDIA FOCUSES ON
OTHER THINGS.
WE KEEP HEARING MORE ABOUT THE
MISTAKES.
AUTHORITIES RECEIVED MANY TIPS
WARNING THEM CRUZ WAS GOING TO
DO SOMETHING BAD, INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY A MASS SHOOTING.
THEN THERE IS THE DEPUTY FAILING
TO CONVERT THE SHOOTER.
THE SHERIFF DENIED THESE FACTS
BEFORE AND NOW DOES ALL HE CAN
SHAVE HIS     -- SAVE HIS JOB.
>> I GAVE HIM A GUN.
I GAVE HIM A BADGE.
I GAVE HIM THE TRAINING.
IF HE DIDN'T HAVE THE HEART TO
GO IN, THAT'S NOT MY
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Greg: THAT IS SOME LEADER.
REMEMBER THIS CNN TOWN HALL?
KNOWING THE LAPSES IN HIS
LEADERSHIP, HE DIVERTED THE
AUDIENCE AWAY FROM HIS OWN
INCOMPETENCE TOWARD DANA LOESCH,
WHO PROBABLY WOULD'VE DONE A
BETTER JOB THAN HIM.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOUR STANDING UP
FOR THE NRA AND THAT IS WHAT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO BUT YOU
JUST TOLD THIS GROUP OF PEOPLE
YOU ARE STANDING UP FOR THEM.
YOU ARE NOT STANDING UP FOR THEM
UNTIL YOU SAY "I WANT LESS
WEAPONS."
>> Greg: THE REAL DISGRACE,
KNOWING WHAT HE KNEW THEN I'M
PLAYING THAT CARD FOR APPLAUSE.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD BE MAD BUT NOT
AT THE NRA.
AT THIS DUDE.
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT THE DEPUTY
AND SAYS HE'S ONLY RESPONSIBLE
UP TO A POINT, IS HE RIGHT?
HE WASN'T THERE SO IT WASN'T HIS
PROBLEM?
>> Kimberly: THE LANGUAGE FROM
HIS RHETORIC SHOWS HIS LACK OF
INTEGRITY, LACK OF LEADERSHIP
SKILLS AND QUALITIES.
HE'S THE HEAD BOSS.
HE SHOULD BE THE ONE TAKING
OWNERSHIP OF THE SITUATION AND
MAKING IT A TEACHABLE MOMENT IN
SAYING THIS IS SOMETHING THEY
COULD'VE DONE BETTER.
THE DEPUTY SHOULD HAVE GONE IN.
THEY HAD THE TRAINING.
THEY SHOULD RE-EXAMINE
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS.
MAYBE THEY ARE NOT MAKING IT
REAL ENOUGH.
PEOPLE AREN'T CONFRONTED ENOUGH
WITH SITUATIONS LIKE THIS TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SNAP DECISIONS.
FOR THIS GUY SEEMS LIKE HE IS
PLAYING TO THE THEATER.
HE THINKS HE IS SOME CHARACTER,
FLAWED FOR SURE, AND A
SHAKESPEAREAN PLAY AND HE WANTS
TO PLAY TO THE CROWD AND THE
MORE ADULATION THEY GIVE HIM,
THE BETTER HE FEELS.
YOU SEE IT BY THOSE MOMENTS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU KNOW WHAT HE
KNEW AT THE TIME, HOW HE BEHAVED
IN THE TOWN HALL.
THAT'S WHY SOME PEOPLE ARE
CALLING FOR HIM TO RESIGN.
>> Greg: OR AT LEAST BE
SUSPENDED, JESSE.
WHEN HE SAID, HE MENTIONED HIS
AMAZING LEADERSHIP.
TRYING TO STEAL FROM
DONALD TRUMP'S VERNACULAR?
DIDN'T WORK.
>> Jesse: LIKE HILLARY AFTER
BENGHAZI, IF SHE HAD RAISED HER
LEADERSHIP.
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME.
HE ACTS LIKE A POLITICIAN
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T ACCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY PRETTY HE
SWITCHED PARTIES TO RUN FOR
OFFICE.
ACCUSED OF RUNNING A PAGE OR
JUDGMENTAL.
HE'S COMPARING HIMSELF TO MLK,
GANDHI, AND ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S IT?
>> Jesse: SOUNDS LIKE YOUR
TYPICAL POLITICIAN.
ONE DEPUTY DIDN'T GO IN AND THEN
WHEN MORE DEPUTY SHOWED UP, THEY
DIDN'T GO INTO THE BUILDING.
THEY WERE EITHER COWARDS, THEY
BROKE PROTOCOL OR HAVE THE WRONG
PROTOCOL.
WE WILL FIND OUT WHICH ONE IT
IS.
WE ALSO KNOW THEY WERE CALLED 23
TIMES ABOUT THIS GUY.
TWO TIMES THEY WERE WARNED HE
WAS GOING TO BE A POSSIBLE
SCHOOL SHOOTER.
NOW HE IS RUNNING A P.R.
CAMPAIGN, GOING ON CNN, BLAMING
THE NRA, NOT ROOTS ATTEMPTING
THE NRA, NOT ROOTS ATTEMPTING  -
THE NRA, NOT ROOTS ATTEMPTING  N
THE NRA, NOT ROOTS ATTEMPTING  T
ACCEPTING RESPONSIBILITY.
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE HE'S MORE
CONCERNED WITH BASHING THE NRA
THAN SOLVING THE SCHOOL SAFETY
ISSUE.
DEMOCRATS FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAD SAID POLICE
HIGHER STANDARD, NEED MORE
SCRUTINY.
NOW THEY HAVE NO APPETITE TO
LOOK INTO IT.
REPUBLICANS USUALLY GIVE POLICE
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT BUT AT
THIS POINT, THEIRS, LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S A LOT OF MISTAKES THAT
WERE MADE.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO INVESTIGATE
HERE.
I THINK THAT'S FINE.
INVESTIGATE.
LET THE FACTS FALL WHERE THEY
MAY.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE A COVER-UP,
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE MIGHT
BE A COVER-UP GOING ON.
>> Greg: DANA, WHEN YOU
WATCHED THE JAKE TAPPER
INTERVIEW SUNDAY, DO YOU THINK
HE REALIZED THE SHERIFF HAD
FLEECED HIM AT THE TOWN HALL AND
THIS WAS PAYBACK?
ALL RIGHT, YOU KNEW THIS STUFF.
>> Dana: HE DOES IT IN A WAY
THAT'S CLASSY.
HE DOESN'T DRAG HIM THROUGH THE
MUD.
GIVEN THE CHANCE TO ANSWER AND
THE ANSWERS, AS YOU POINTED OUT,
OR HORRIBLE.
THERE WAS NO SIMPLE THING FOR
VICTIMS OR FAMILIES.
IT WAS ALL DEFENSIVENESS.
HONESTLY I THOUGHT IT WAS
DELUSIONAL.
I WONDER, IF HE THINKS HE DID
NOTHING WRONG.
I BELIEVE IN THE MILITARY, IF
YOUR SOLDIERS DON'T FOLLOW
THROUGH, YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE.
OR ELSE IT DOESN'T WORK.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A CHAIN OF
COMMAND THAT'S FOLLOWED, THE
CHAIN WILL BREAK.
>> Greg: JUAN, DO YOU THINK HE
DESERVES SOME KIND OF
DISCIPLINE?
THERE IS TALK OF SUSPENSION, OR
SHOULD HE RESIGN?
THE GOVERNOR CAN FIRE HIM, EVEN
THOUGH HE'S AN ELECTED OFFICIAL,
I BELIEVE.
>> Juan: THIS CONVERSATION
AND, TO ME, IS WAY OFF IN THE
WEEDS.
WE NEED TO BE TALKING ABOUT IS
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEAD.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
DOING.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Greg: IF SOMEBODY REACTED
TO THE SHOOTER, THEY WOULD BE
ALIVE.
>> Juan: NO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID EVEN
WITHOUT A WEAPON, HE WOULD'VE
RUN IN.
THE POINT IS THE DEAD YOUNG
PEOPLE.
TO ME, YOU SEE NOW THIS RUSH OF
REPUBLICANS TO BLAME THE FBI, TO
BLAME THE SHERIFF OF THE COUNTY.
NEVER, EVER TO TALK ABOUT THE
NRA, THE PROLIFERATION OF GUNS
IN SOCIETY, THIS WACKO YOUNG
MAN, UNDERAGE, UNDER 21, ABLE TO
GET AN ASSAULT RIFLE.
WE CAN GO BACK AND FORTH ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT YOU SHOULD FIRE
SHERIFF ISRAEL.
FINE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Greg: THAT WAS THE TOPIC
TODAY, JUAN.
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT A
PRACTICAL SOLUTION.
>> Greg: I THINK IT IS, IF YOU
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> Juan: DO YOU THINK IT'S
GOING TO STOP MORE SHOOTINGS?
>> Greg:
>> Juan: YOU SAY THINGS LIKE
THE DEATH PENALTY AND STRONG
PUNISHMENT WILL DISCOURAGE
REPEAT CRIMES.
IN THIS CASE, I DON'T SEE THE
GOING AFTER THE SHERIFF OR EVEN
THE DEPUTY, AND DANA, HE THINKS
HE DID A GOOD JOB.
HIS LAWYER PUT OUT A STATEMENT
SAYING HE WAS THE FIRST TO CALL
IN.
>> Dana: I WASN'T TALKING
ABOUT PETERSON.
I WAS TALKING ABOUT ISRAEL.
>> Juan: IT SEEMS THE
CONVERSATION IS LIKE A POLITICAL
PLOY BY REPUBLICANS.
>> Greg: THE POLITICS STARTED
IN THE TOWN HALL WHEN HE TRIED
TO DIVERT THE RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR THE ACTIONS.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
AMERIAN SOLUTIONS FOR TO FUTURE
GUN VIOLENCE, LET'S ROLL THIS
TAPE.
DONALD TRUMP MENTIONING THE NRA.
>> DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE NRA.
THEY ARE ON OUR SIDE.
HALF OF YOU ARE SO AFRAID OF THE
NRA.
THERE IS NOTHING TO BE AFRAID
OF.
YOU KNOW WHAT, IF THEY ARE NOT
WITH YOU, WE HAVE TO FIGHT THEM
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE.
THAT'S OKAY.
THEY ARE DOING WHAT THEY THINK
IS RIGHT.
SOMETIMES WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO BE TOUGH AND FIGHT THEM.
WE NEED STRONG BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME,
PEOPLE RESISTED THAT.
BUT I NOW THINK PEOPLE ARE
REALLY INTO IT.
>> Greg: HOW POLITICAL IS
THAT?
SEEMS LIKE THE MOST
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD.
CLOSE TO ONE HAND AND THEN THE
OTHER ON THE NRA.
>> Jesse: IT'S PRETTY HONEST.
FOR A POLITICIAN, TAKES A LOT OF
COURAGE TO TAKE ON SOMEONE WHO
HAS BEEN BACK IN YOUR PARTY FOR
DECADES.
JUAN MAKES THE POINT LIKE YOU
CAN'T CHEW GUM AND WALK AT THE
SAME TIME.
REPUBLICANS HAVE CRITICIZED THIS
SHERIFF AND HAVE ALSO PUT
FORWARD SOLUTIONS TO SCHOOL
SAFETY.
SAYING RAISE THE LIMIT FOR
PURCHASING AN ERROR 15, BANNING
BUMP STOCKS.
ALL WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE LEFT
IS, LET'S JUST CRUCIFY THE NRA.
I'M GLAD YOU THINK POLICE JUST
NEED TO BE TRUSTED WILLY-NILLY
AND EVERYTHING IS PERFECT.
WHEN THEY MAKE MISTAKES, YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Juan: YES.
>> Jesse: YOU DON'T THINK THEY
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
I BELIEVE THESE PEOPLE ARE
PRAYING FOR -- PAID FOR BY
TAXPAYER MONEY.
THEY SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU WANT TO GIVE THEM A PASS.
>> Juan: WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
>> Jesse: HUGE AESTHETICS.
YOU DON'T CARE.
>> Juan: THIS IS A DIVERSION.
BUMP STOCKS, HOW LONG HAS
CONGRESS HAD TO ACT?
>> Jesse: EVERYBODY WANTS THEM
BANNED.
>> Juan: IT WOULD BE A
DIVERSION IF SOMETHING HAD BEEN
DONE.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY IS RAISING A
HAND.
>> Kimberly: HERE'S THE
PROBLEM.
IF WE WANT TO BE HONEST, ALL
THESE THINGS SHOULD BE EXAMINED.
TO GIVE CREDIT, THE PRESIDENT
HAD A LISTENING SESSION TO
DISCUSS IT.
THEY BROUGHT UP WEAPONS.
THEY BROUGHT UP GUNS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID WE NEED TO
EXAMINE ALL THIS.
MAYBE WE NEED TO RAISE THE AGE.
MAYBE WE NEED TO MAKE IT SO
BUMP STOCKS AREN'T AVAILABLE.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE IN PLAY
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN WE SHOULD BE
DERELICT IN OUR DUTY TO DO AN
EXAMINATION OF THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT, JUST LIKE WITH THE
FBI, TO MAKE SURE THE RIGHT
PROTOCOLS WERE IN PLACE.
TO MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN.
IT'S HEALTHY AND RESPONSIBLE AT
ITS COMPETENCY.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
HERE.
ALL OF THIS IS APPROPRIATE
DISCUSSION, JUST LIKE WE SHOULD
DISCUSS THE SHERIFF HERE,
ISRAEL, AND WHETHER OR NOT HE IS
THE RIGHT PERSON TO BE DOING
THAT JOB.
I THINK THE ANSWER IS CLEAR.
>> Greg: DANA, WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT DIVERSIONS AND POLITICAL
AGENDAS, IT'S LIKE THE NRA
DISCOUNT STORY IS KIND OF LIKE A
DIVERSION AWAY.
EVERYBODY HERE AT THIS TABLE,
DONALD TRUMP AT HIS LISTENING
EVENT, THERE IS EVERYTHING FROM
CIVIL TAGS TO HARDENING SOFT
TARGETS.
HOW DOES BANNING NRA DISCOUNTS
ARE GETTING RID OF IT, HOW DOES
THAT HELP?
>> Dana: UNITED AIRLINES FROM
ENTERPRISE RENT-A-CAR, I THINK
HERZ JOINED IN.
NOW DELTA.
IN THIS SCENARIO.
I UNDERSTAND THERE IS GOING TO
BE OPPOSITION TO THE NRA.
JUST LIKE THERE IS OPPOSITION TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
THE MIRROR ORGANIZATION FOR
IDEOLOGY.
IN THIS SITUATION, YOU TALK
ABOUT SEE SOMETHING, SAY
SOMETHING SHOULD LEAD TO DO
SOMETHING AND WE KNOW THEY DO
CASE.
WHY WOULD YOU TAKE THAT OUT ON
DUES PAYING MEMBERS OF THE NRA
WHO WANT TO RENT A CAR FROM YOU.
LARRY PUNISHING THEM?
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL IN GEORGIA
IS SAYING DELTA, WE ARE GOING TO
COME BACK AT YOU AND TAKE AWAY
YOUR TAX BREAK.
THIS IS GOING TO LEAD NOWHERE.
A CORPORATION HAS THE RIGHT TO
MAKE A DECISION.
IF THEY WANT TO LOSE CUSTOMERS,
FINE.
IF IT MEANS THAT MUCH TO THEM
AND THEY WANT TO TAKE THE P.R.
HIT OR MAYBE THEY THINK THEY GET